we're told to graph the inequality Y is
less than 3x plus 5 so you give me any X
Y is going to be less than three times
that X plus five so the way to think
about it is you want to think about the
line y equals 3x plus 5 but since we're
going to be less than that instead of
drawing that line we're gonna draw it as
a dotted line and then shade all the Y's
that are less than that so let me show
you what I mean so if we wanted to just
draw 3x plus 5 if this was just any and
equality if we wanted to draw that graph
I'll do it in this dark green color we'd
say okay the y-intercept here is
positive 5 so we'd go 1 2 3 4 5 and we
would say the slope is 3 which means if
we move one in the X direction we move
up three one in the x direction we move
up three if we move back in the X
direction we're gonna move down three if
we move back in the x direction down
three if we move back two we're gonna go
down six two four six just like that now
if this was graphing the line y is equal
to 3x plus five we would just connect
all of these dots but because we're not
less than or equal to we're just less
than we're gonna do a dotted line here
to show that the line is actually not
going to be included so let me draw a
dotted line here which is actually
surprisingly easier to draw than a
regular line so that is a dotted line
we're not going to include that line
we're going to include all the Y's that
are less than 3x plus 5 so let's think
about it for a second if you give me
some arbitrary X so let's say that X is
0 if X is 0 then what's 3x plus 5 well 3
times 0 plus 5 is 5 so y is going to be
less than that if X is 0 y has to be
less than 5 so Y is going to be all of
these values down here all of these and
it would not include in a few were doing
as a number line you would do a circle
over there you would not include 5 if X
was equal to if X was equal to 1 what is
3x plus 5 3 times 1 is 3 plus five is
eight so Y would have to be less than 8
8 is over here so it's all the values
less than 8 over here so in general for
any X
over here the Y's that are less than
three X plus five are all of the values
are all of the values below the dotted
line all of these values below the
dotted line is the graph of the
inequality Y is less than three X plus
five is less than or equal to you would
make that a solid line but it's not so
it's just all of this area down here all
of this area below this line that's what
that less than tells you